[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to the MIT Center for
Art, Science and Technology
2021 Symposium, Unfolding
Intelligence, the Art
and Science of
Contemporary Computation.
CAS was established
in 2012 with the goal
of building and
building on connections
between the worlds of art,
science, and technology.
This is the third in
a series of symposia
the CAS has convened since then.
And as with its predecessors,
we bring together
artists, scientists, engineers,
and humanists from within MIT
and from the world
at large to discuss
areas of rapidly
evolving research
and urgent social relevance,
and define in that dialogue
stimulation, confirmation,
provocation, intersection,
and we hope common purpose.
At MIT, CAS partners with
departments, labs, and centers
to integrate the arts
across the curriculum
to enrich and encourage artistic
collaboration, and to provide
support to faculty and
members of the MIT community
as they pursue their
own artistic practice
and/or research.
In addition to
symposia like this,
CAS facilitates the sharing
of this creative work
beyond the Institute
by producing concerts,
exhibitions, and
publications, and making
them available to the public.
So thank you for
being with us today.
We hope you will join
us throughout the week
at virtual events addressing
the aesthetic, technical,
and critical issues pertaining
to artificial intelligence
and computational media.
We also look forward to
seeing you on Friday,
April 9 as the
symposium culminates
with a live interactive event
to which all attendees are
invited, and which you can
join presenters and artists
in breakout rooms to explore
hidden threads between all that
has been discussed this week.
Welcome to our
panel on bias and AI
for exploring all of the kind of
issues where we can understand
how algorithms have been
leveraged for a number
of technological advances,
at the same time as encoding
a number of types of
discriminatory practices
these days.
Terms like bias, and
AI, and algorithmic bias
have nearly entered the
common parlance these days.
But it wasn't always the case.
Even though many
technologies in the past
have also implemented bias.
So for example, we
could think back
towards collaborative filtering
algorithms, commonly used
and commonly
benefited from today,
whether it's from
recommendations for purchases,
or songs, and so forth.
At the same time, when you look
at how collaborative filtering
algorithms work, these
algorithms that are frequently
used in recommender
systems, you can
say that they build consensus
in a particular way that
can encode bias.
That is you can think about
the collaborative filtering
algorithm as a very, as working
on a very sparse matrix.
That is, if you imagine
a kind of a system
where you have all of
the users of the system
along a vertical axis
and all of the items
that can be recommended
along the horizontal axis,
you're going to know--
then the system is going
to try to figure out
for each cell would
that person want
to purchase, or understand,
or use that particular item?
So you can see that
most of those cells
are going to be filled,
and the algorithm is going
to have to try to fill it.
It would do so by trying
to find networks of users,
like minded users, and build
consensus, show those items
to those users more.
And then you have this
escalating process
of consensus building,
in which case
all the individuals
will tend to converge
towards similar preferences.
In fact, in the early literature
around collaborate filtering
algorithms, people who didn't
fit neatly into the rubric
were called in early
papers either black sheep
or white sheep, tellingly.
Fields such as computer
support co-operative work
within computer
science have long
looked at issues like
the sociotechnical gap,
trying to understand
why systems often
fail for social reasons rather
than technological reasons.
Thinkers such as Phil
[? Agery ?] and Terri Winograd
have been critics of AI.
And Fill in
particular suggesting
this idea of critical
technical practices
where we consider
their foundations as we
think about how we
engineer systems.
And then sociology of science,
we have people like Bruno
[? Latour ?] who
would look at how
people and systems all within
the same network exchange
values with one another.
Now the term bias and
AI has proliferated
in part because of the use of
artificial neural networks.
These used to be--
used-- 20 and 30
years ago primarily
either for particular classes
of engineering problems
or in cases where
computer scientists
wanted enhanced
biological plausibility.
However, 20 years ago, they
weren't in as widespread use
as today because such
systems were criticized
for a variety of reasons, such
as biological plausibility
as we learned that it's not
just whether a neuron fires,
but the rate of fire,
and much more that
determines its operation
within the human brain.
But now with the exception
of deep learning,
the classes of
problems have expanded
immensely that artificial
neural networks can approach.
And because of
this proliferation
of using artificial
neural networks,
the inclusion with the
enhanced media attention
around particular kind
of social issues of bias,
then this topic of bias and
AI has become more well known.
As Jeff [INAUDIBLE] and
[? Lee ?] Starr have put it,
we can combine our technical
and scientific approaches
with the wisdom of race critical
and feminist scholarship
in order to more
completely understand
the kind of operation
of these systems.
Hence, the panel
from today is aimed
to allow us to benefit from
the insights of computer
science, sociology, reflective
technologies from the arts,
all to gain different
perspectives
on the issue of bias and AI.
And I want to finally just
mention one other point related
to bias and AI before I begin
to introduce our panelists.
It's that we can
turn the lens around.
So I've been really pleased
in some of our own work
to use deep learning or
statistical techniques
such as archetypal
analysis to try
to understand why it's widely
used systems such as avatars,
and games, and social
media, social media
profiles, and more.
And expose the kind of
biases and that they
tend to implement, such
as not being optimized
for particular
categories of people
as regards to race or
gender in particular.
So to begin with, I
mentioned benefiting
from the wisdom of sociology,
computer science, and the arts.
We have first of
all Ruha Benjamin
who specializes in
interdisciplinary study
of science, medicine,
technology, race, ethnicity,
gender, and knowledge and power.
She's the author
of People Science:
Bodies and Rights on
the stem cell frontier
and race after technology.
And she is a professor
at Duke University.
She has written numerous
articles and book chapters,
been awarded fellowships
and grants from the National
Science Foundation, Ford
Foundation, and much more.
In computer science and
information science,
we have Jon Kleinberg.
His research focuses on
interaction of algorithms
and networks, and the roles
they play in large scale
social information systems.
His work has been supported
by NSF Career Award, ONR Young
Investigator Award, MacArthur
Fellowship, Sloan Foundation
Fellowship, and
much more, as well
as grants from
Facebook, Google, Yahoo,
but MacArthur
Foundation and the NSF.
And many other organizations.
And in terms of reflecting
on these kind of systems
that we have Behnaz Farahi
here who is an award winning
designer, critical maker
based in Los Angeles
who holds a PhD in
interdisciplinary and media
arts and practice from USC
School of Cinematic Arts.
She explores how to foster
an empathetic relationship
between the human body
and space and space
around it using
computational systems,
addressing issues ranging from
emotion to social interaction.
And she uses fabrication
techniques along
with computational
design in her work.
Her work is in the
permanent collection
the Museum of Science
and Industry in Chicago.
She's been exhibited
internationally
in Arts Electronica and more.
And featured across the popular
press, ranging from BBC,
to The Guardian, Wired, and
many other journalistic venues.
And finally, she is also a
recipient of many fellowships
too, such as the Rock
Hudson Fellowship.
So I'm very, very
pleased to have
these distinguished
panelists with us here today.
First off is going
to be Ruha Benjamin.
You will see a recorded
video of her speaking.
And afterwards, we'll return for
a few live verifying questions
before continuing on
with our other panelists
in a similar format.
And then going to a broad
panel discussion and Q&A.
So without further ado, I'd
like to hand it off and begin
Ruha's presentation.
Thank you so much
for the invitation
to be part of this conversation.
When it comes to our theme,
unfolding intelligence,
I want to suggest that to
talk about intelligence
is to talk about eugenics.
For many people, the E word
conjures a particular place--
Nazi, Germany.
Forgetting that
the Nazis learned
from US based
scientists and doctors,
and that Hitler called
Madison Grant's book,
The Passing of the
Great Race his Bible.
The word eugenics also
conjures a specific time period
that we have supposedly passed,
when in fact, eugenic logics
and imaginaries continue
to infect so many areas
of our contemporary lives.
From the way patients
are treated and triaged,
to the way that schoolchildren
are ranked and rated.
In short, the
eugenics period never
ended, but rather unfolded.
Mercurial in the way that it
has taken on different forms
and functions, including
in our present age of AI.
For our conversation
today, I want
to briefly highlight the
entanglement between eugenics
and statistics.
And since we're still in the
midst of the spring semester,
I'd like to assign
some homework,
and encourage everyone to read
this article authored by Aubrey
Clayton a few months ago.
Published a few months ago.
In it she writes that
ideally, statisticians
would like to divorce these
tools from the lives and times
of the people who created them.
It would be convenient
if statistics
existed outside of history,
but that's not the case.
Statistics as a lens through
which scientists investigate
real world questions
has always been
smudged by the fingerprints of
the people holding the lens.
Statistical thinking
and eugenicists thinking
are in fact deeply intertwined.
And many of the
theoretical problems
with methods like significance
testing first developed
to identify racial
differences are
remnants of their original
purpose to support eugenics.
In other words, eugenics haunts
any discussion of intelligence.
So if statistical thinking
will not save us, what will?
Black feminist
thought, of course.
And here I draw upon the
wisdom of Toni Cade Bambara
when she writes, "Not
all speed is movement."
Again, this idea
could be applied
into so many different
areas of our lives.
But here I want us to think
about it in the context
of technological development.
Which too often is conflated,
falsely, with social progress.
Technological development can
actually reinforce and sediment
social inequalities.
In fact, its default
settings should have it
that we shouldn't be
surprised when it does.
And this idea is
easier to translate
and to shape our
critical thinking
when it comes to the past.
It's easier to recognize
when technology and data have
been used to harm
different groups,
whether it's the Deadly
Data that IBM helped
in supporting the Holocaust
in terms of punch cards
to surveil and track
populations that
were eventually exterminated.
But it's harder, I think, to
apply this to our present,
especially when it comes to
what we might call Do-Gooding
Data where the
framing and the motive
is to purportedly
help different groups.
In this case, a quick
example comes to us
from Minnesota where the
public school district there
and the police
department joined forces
under the umbrella of what they
call the Innovation Project.
And this was a
project that intended
to collect and centralize
data from a number
of different local
agencies in order
to help predict the riskiness
of young people, their risk
of having future encounters
with law enforcement.
The do-gooding aspect
was that these agencies
hoped to intervene early.
But ultimately, the community
rallied around and put an end
to this innovation project,
pointing to the fact
that the vast majority
of these agencies
actually did not
have a good track
record when it
came to supporting
the well-being of young people.
They pointed in
particular to the data
that would be used as the
input for this project.
The different
attendance records,
whether family members
had been involved
with the criminal
justice system,
Child Protective Services.
So all of the
input data actually
were drawn from agencies
and institutions that
have routinely harmed, surveil,
and mistreat young people.
So why should the community
expect a different outcome,
a good outcome?
And so again, it's
harder to think
about this critically in light
of the questions of eugenics
and how this supports the
ranking and the rating
of different groups.
And so as a starting
point to think critically
about our present moment,
our do-gooding efforts,
I want to suggest that when it
comes to computational depth,
deep learning, machine
learning, without
historical and sociological
depth, what we're actually
producing is
superficial learning.
We really have to situate our
questions, and our designs,
and our goals in a much deeper,
historical, and social context
so that we don't unwittingly
reproduce racial inequalities
and social inequities.
And so let's apply
this insight just
for a moment to a
particular setting.
Let's look at it in the
context of health care.
Again, there's
mounds of research
that really shows
the various ways
in which racial discrimination
operates in our health care
system.
And it's not simply at
the structural level,
although that's important.
That is at the level
of policies and laws.
But also interpersonally,
in terms of the way
that health care professionals
treat different patients.
And one set of a part
of this literature
is looking at how doctors
routinely underestimate
the pain of Black patients.
And don't prescribe them
the necessary treatments
and medication that
they might need.
So a question for
us would be, what
would it look like
to actually outsource
these decisions to AI?
Would that make it more
fair, more equitable?
Would that be a way to bypass
the existing social biases
and forms of discrimination
in our health care system?
And so my recent work
has been wrestling
with this and similar
questions in which I
describe the combination
of coded bias
and imagined objectivity
as the new Jim Code.
Innovation that enables
social containment,
while appearing fairer than
discriminatory practices
of a previous era.
What I'm drawing attention
to what this concept is
that technology can actually
hide the ongoing nature
of social domination
and allow it
to penetrate every
facet of our lives
under the guise of progress.
And what I'm encouraging
us to think about
is how anti-Blackness gets
encoded in and exercised
through automated
systems by offering
four conceptual offspring to the
new Jim Code that follow along
kind of spectrum.
From the most obvious
variety, engineered inequity,
to the most insidious--
techno benevolence.
And for the sake
of time, I'm just
going to sketch the last element
of this, techno benevolence,
and then move towards
some concluding thoughts.
So techno benevolence
refers to those technologies
that aim to address
bias in various ways.
Take for example
new AI techniques
for vetting job applicants.
A company called Hirevue aims
to quote, "Reduce unconscious
bias and promote
diversity in the workplace
by using an AI
powered program that
analyzes recorded interviews
of prospective employees."
So it uses thousands
of data points,
including verbal and nonverbal
cues like facial expression,
posture, vocal tone.
And then it compares
job seekers' scores
to those of existing
top performing employees
to decide who to flag
as a desirable hire
and who to reject.
Another value added,
according to Hirevue
is that there's a lot that
a human interviewer misses
that AI can keep track
of to make quote,
"Data driven talent decisions."
After all, the problem of
employment discrimination
is widespread and
well documented.
So the logic goes, wouldn't
this be even more reason
to outsource decisions to AI?
Well consider that question
in light of a study
by a Princeton team
of computer scientists
that examined whether a
popular algorithm trained
on human writing online
exhibited the same racially
biased tendencies
that psychologists
have documented among humans.
In particular, they found
that the algorithm associated
white sounding names
with pleasant words,
and Black sounding names
with unpleasant ones.
Which builds on a
classic audit study
from about 2003, in which
two University of Chicago
economists sent out
thousands of resumes
to employers in
Boston and Chicago
and just changed the
names on the resumes.
Some had names like
Emily and Greg.
Some names like
Lakisha and Jamal.
And what they found was that
the white sounding names
received 50% more callbacks.
And so simply
turning to technology
to solve that form of employment
bias is not going to save us.
So too with gender
coded words and names.
As Amazon learned
a few years ago
when its own hiring
algorithm was found
discriminating against women.
Nevertheless, it
should be clear why
technical fixes that claim
to bypass human biases
are so desirable.
If only there was a
way to slay centuries
of racist and sexist demons
with a social justice bot.
Beyond desirable,
more like magical,
magical for employers
perhaps looking
to streamline the grueling
work of recruitment,
but a curse from
any job seekers.
As this headline puts
it, "Your next interview
could be with a racist bot."
Bringing us back to that
problem space we started with.
So it's worth noting that
some job seekers are already
developing ways to subvert
the system by trading answers
to employers' tests, and
creating fake applications
as informal audits of their own.
In terms of public policy, the
algorithmic accountability bill
is one effort in the US
to create some protections
around the ubiquity of
automated and AI based decisions
in our everyday lives.
It's a start, but in
no way sufficient.
Another development that
keeps me somewhat hopeful
is that tech workers
themselves have increasingly
been speaking out against
the most egregious forms
of corporate collusion with
state sanctioned racism.
For example, Microsoft employees
opposed to the company's ICE
contract stated that,
"As the people who
build the technologies that
Microsoft profits from,
we refuse to be complicit."
And in just the last few months,
the Alphabet Workers Union
has been gaining momentum.
And so for anyone in the
tech industry listening here,
I would encourage you
to look up these efforts
and stay connected.
And as this article
published by Science
for the People
reminds us, "Contrary
to popular
narratives, organizing
among technical workers
has a vibrant history,
including engineers and
technicians in the '60s
and '70s who fought
professionalism, individualism,
and reformism to contribute
to radical labor organizing."
The current tech
workers movement,
which includes students
across our many institutions,
can draw from these past
organizers' strategies
and challenges and learning
to navigate the contradictions
and complexities of
organizing in tech today.
In terms of education, which
I think of as the ground
zero for planting a more
historically and socially
situated approach
to STEM, I'll just
mention one concrete resource
that you can download called,
The Advancing Racial Literacy
In Tech Handbook, which
was developed by some wonderful
colleagues at the Data
and Society Research
Institute in New York.
The aim of this
intervention is threefold--
to develop an
intellectual understanding
of how structural racism
operates in algorithms,
social media platforms, and
technologies not yet developed.
An emotional
intelligence concerning
how to resolve racially
stressful situations
within organizations,
and a commitment
to take action to reduce
harms to communities of color.
In that spirit,
initiatives like data
for Black Lives and the
Detroit Community Tech Project
are just two of the many
different tech justice
organizations that exist
all over the world.
Data for Black Lives
brings together
people working across a number
of agencies and organizations
in a proactive approach
to tech justice,
especially at the policy level.
And the Detroit Community
Technology Project
develops and uses
technology rooted
in community needs, offering
support to grassroots networks,
doing data justice research.
Including hosting what
they call Discotechs, which
stands for discovering
technology,
which are these multimedia
mobile and neighborhood
workshop fairs that can be
adapted in other locales.
In the end, it boils
down to whose knowledge?
Or we might say
whose intelligence
we're enfolding into our
socio-technical systems?
Who are we listening to?
Returning to the issue
of medical racism
it turns out if AI is
trained on doctors' reports,
it will draw discriminatory
and faulty conclusions.
According to the researchers,
we didn't train the algorithm
to predict what the doctor was
going to say about the X-ray,
we trained it to predict
what the patient was
going to say about their own
experience of pain in the knee.
And these predictions,
from the patients' reports
were actually much
more accurate.
Who would have guessed?
So here's my final proposition.
If it is the case that
inequity and injustice is
woven into the very
fabric of our society,
then that means each
twist, coil, and code
is a chance for us to weave
new patterns, practices,
and politics.
The vastness of the problems
that we're up against
will be their undoing
once we accept
that we are pattern makers.
And so if as I
suggested at the start
an ahistoric and asocial
approach to science
and technology
captures and contains,
that means a historically
and socially grounded
approach can open up
possibilities and pathways.
It can create new settings,
and code new values,
and build on critical
intellectual traditions that
have continuously developed
insights and strategies
grounded in justice.
And my hope is that
we all find ways
to build on this tradition.
Thank you for your attention.
So thank you so much, Ruha, for
the fascinating and incisive
talk.
And one of the things
I was struck by
was the way that you describe
the kind of benevolence,
the so-called
benevolence approach
that people might bring
to these communities,
as if a kind of a savior
model in particular ways.
So I wonder if you can
look at the other side
and say a bit more
about what you
see as community
projects that have
been successful
that are emerging
from within communities.
And this is one of my students
has called critical community
technologies.
And what are the
conditions under which
you've seen such
groups flourish where
they have been the ones that
everything these technologies?
Thank you so much, Fox.
And thanks to all the organizers
behind the screen helping
us to convene in this space
and this conversation.
And so there's different ways
that this is taking shape.
And I think that there's
no one set of conditions
or requirements that I think
can make technology more
empowering, less oppressive.
The ones that I
find fascinating is
when these digital
tools are turned back
on those who wield power and
who monopolize resources.
Sometimes in longer
versions of the talk,
I'll mention a parody example
called the White Collar Early
Warning System, which
is not community based,
but it's an artistic, a
creative sort of rendering
of what it means to take
these tools that are typically
targeting the most
disenfranchised communities
and turn it back to
those who produce
risk for those very
same populations.
And so there's examples
like that subversive turning
of the digital tools that
sometimes enroll or collaborate
with communities to make happen.
Then there are the examples that
I hinted at like the Detroit
Community Technology Project.
There's a New York based version
of that in which it's really
about generating meaningful
questions as a starting point
for any kind of design project.
I think sometimes what we think
about community collaboration,
researchers, we huddle,
we come up with something
and then we go out and
try to find communities
to collaborate with.
Rather than really starting at
ground zero with the generation
of questions.
To me, that's where so much
of the power is concentrated.
The fact that people can't
ask meaningful questions
about their lives,
about their world,
and then have the resources
to produce the data,
produce the tools that
would help them answer
and intervene in those issues.
And so one of the places that
I'm trying to work on that
is at the Ida B.
Wells Just Data Lab
here at Princeton
in which I have
teams of undergrad students
who partner with communities
to generate questions and then
the projects that come out
of that as to me a
better starting point.
So rather than us think about,
OK this is what we want to do,
and then go find
community partners.
So the Ida B.
Wells Just Data Lab
is one example
housed in academia.
But there are
other examples that
come out of more policy
or advocacy, orientation.
There are
anti-surveillance types
of projects, some that are more
creative in which people are
creating fashion that are
anti-surveillance fashion
examples versus the LAPD's
coalition to stop surveillance
in Los Angeles and other places.
So I think the
take-home is that this
can take many, many
different forms,
from on a continuum of
more critical countering
subversive to creative
self-fashioning and community
based participatory research.
Whether that's in the context
of environmental justice or data
justice, there are
so many examples.
And so for those who
are looking to plug-in,
I would encourage them to
visit the Resources tab
of my personal website,
ruhabenjamin.com/resources.
And you'll see it, a
really long list of places
to plug-in in your own backyard.
And especially for the students
who might be listening.
Sometimes when we are
awakened to issues like this,
we want to start our own thing.
The entrepreneurial
spirit and I would
encourage us to plug into
things that already exist
as a starting point,
rather than jump the gun
and try to come
up the solutions.
Going back to your savior,
the idea of a savior complex.
And so I hope that
gives folks enough
to chew on as a
place to get started.
It does, it's so fascinating.
And you bring to mind projects
such as, The Million Dollar
Blocks Project.
Looking at the amount
of money, mapping
the amount of money used in
communities for incarceration,
it prompts people to think
about other types of issues
and where their money
could have gone.
So it just seems like
exactly the kind of literacy
and reversing the lens
that you describe.
And so thank you, thank
you once again very much.
And so next up, we
have Jon Kleinberg,
professor at Cornell University
who is going to speak.
And I think it's a very nice
compliment to what we've just
seen from Professor Ruha
Benjamin, because he's looking
in some sense under the
hood, but at the same time,
bringing that kind of critical
lens around issues of fairness
as well.
So now let's welcome
our prerecorded video
by Jon Kleinberg, followed again
by a brief, but clarifying Q&A.
It's a pleasure to be able to
take part in this event today.
And I'll be talking about
topics in fairness and bias
in algorithmics decision making.
And I'll be approaching this
as a computer scientist.
But what I'll be
talking about is
joint work with my PhD
student, Manish Raghavan.
And then with three researchers
from three other domains
from Jens Ludwig in Public
Policy, Senhil Mullainathan
in Behavioral Economist,
and Cass Sunstein,
who's a professor of law.
And in some sense to frame
what I'll be talking about,
it's useful to actually go
back to a period of time
when I was a PhD student
at MIT in the mid 1990s.
And there was a
lot of excitement
at that moment about the
way in which an idea that
had been really ubiquitous
in fields like human computer
interaction suddenly became
mainstream through much
of computer science.
And that was the
idea that the systems
we were designing really
had these two different axes
that we have to think about.
There was the technical
axis, along which
we had always organized things.
But then there was also a
social dimension, right?
Where we built
systems and we need
to be sensitive to the social
and economic forces that
underpin them.
In some genuine sense, that
period through the 1990s,
when we saw the
emergence of systems
like the world
wide web, we really
saw the building of
socio-technical systems.
But over the past 10
years, particularly, we've
been discovering that
these systems, even when
we take both of
these into account,
don't always produce the
outcomes that we were hoping.
They end up being awash
in misinformation.
They can lead to conflict
and polarization.
They can produce
decisions that seem
biased against particular
groups of people.
It's almost as though there's
this third dimension that we
haven't been taking
into account,
and much of the momentum
in the past 10 years
of research at the
interface of computing
and the social
sciences has really
been trying to explore what
this third dimension might
look like.
And if I were to
summarize, I might
say it's almost
as though there's
this normative dimension
that we've been missing
in the design of our systems.
That even if we fully
understand, which we certainly
don't, the social and
technical forces at play, even
with all of that
it does not tell us
what outcomes we should
be aiming for, right?
What we might want as a society.
That, in the end, is
a different question.
And so I want to talk about
from the computer science
perspective how
some of these issues
have come into play in
the algorithms, the AI
systems, and the machine
learning protocols that we
have been trying to deploy.
Much of this begins
with a observation
that people have been
making that's gathered
increasing amount of force in
the past few years as well.
Which is to take
ideas that we have
been very good at executing
in the online world, things
like ranking, things
like recommendation
as in this help screen
from a Netflix page.
Where we take
people online and we
with complex sets of
tastes and interests,
we produce feature
vectors to represent them.
And then we try to
make a prediction.
For example, a prediction
about whether they
will like this particular movie,
or what is the probability
they will like this movie?
And people began
asking, if we are
so good at doing this
in the online world,
let's think about situations
in the offline world
where there's something
that looks syntactically
similar going on.
So let's think about
something that's superficially
is quite different, which is
the act of applying for a job.
If we think about
it, we take somebody
with their complex
past work experience.
They produce a tabular
feature-like representation
in the form of a resume.
They submit it to a human hiring
committee that evaluates it.
A very similar pipeline.
And that committee then
makes some kind of a--
well, it's not
clear what they do.
They evaluate some
objective function?
Do they make a prediction?
This is actually where
it gets complicated,
and that tension is
actually what I'll
be trying to get at in my talk.
A similar thing happens with
the college admissions process.
You take someone's grade 9
through 12 educational history,
their interests,
and so forth, turn
into a feature representation.
And again, a committee might
make a decision with an unclear
objective function.
So many things following
this kind of template, right?
Things that we might
call screening decisions.
So when somebody
applies for a job,
there has to be a decision
made, educational admission
decisions, and
many other domains.
The applications for a loan
in the domain of credit,
even in the criminal justice
system where the law instructs
a judge at a pretrial
detention hearing
to make a prediction
about the likelihood
that a defendant will return
for their court appearance
without committing a
crime in the meantime.
And so these are all what
you might call high stakes
decisions.
These are decisions where the
outcome matters significantly
to the individual
being screened, right?
So it matters a lot
if you get this job
you apply for, if you
get into this college
you apply for, and in
all these other examples.
This is not to say that
ranking and recommendation
of online content are somehow
overall low stakes activities.
In the end, it
certainly does not
matter whether
Netflix gets right
whether I like this movie.
In the end, it doesn't matter
whether this particular search
results page has the result I
was particularly looking for.
But we've also seen
over the past few years
that you can take 100 billion
of these low stakes decisions--
search results, news
feed decisions, and they
can add up to something that
is extremely high stakes,
like the formation
of public opinion
as part of the political
process in a large country.
So everything that we do
in this domain I think
has giant ramifications.
The stakes are high.
I focus on these
screen decisions
as being individually
high stakes.
Each individual decision
is actually significant.
And because of this,
it's very natural
and research has turned to this
question of the risks of bias
in these kinds of decisions.
When we deploy
algorithms to make them,
where would we deploy groups
of humans to make them?
And so if we're going to
think about the ways in which
algorithms might introduce
bias into this process,
we should really
start by thinking
about what we know about human
bias in these situations,
because human bias is a profound
factor in all of these domains.
Now well there's
been extensive amount
of research in the behavioral
sciences on human biases,
and including an explosion of
work in the 1990s on topics
in implicit bias.
And a number of now
classical investigations
looked at this
question empirically.
And they found things that are
illustrated by, for example,
this graph on the right
here, which I'll explain.
This comes from a
paper in Nature in 1997
by the European social
scientist, Christine Wennenas
and Agnes Wold.
And so they were interested
in the disparate impact
of screening decisions,
as we are here today.
And so what they
did was they got
records of decisions that
were made on European research
commission grant proposals.
And as part of that process,
the reviewer of the proposal
was supposed to assign a
so-called competence score
to the principal investigator.
How competent are they
to do the research?
And so that's some kind
of a numerical score.
And Vanegas and Vold were
interested in this case
in potential disperate
impacts and the assignment
of this competent
score by gender.
And so what they
did was they looked
at many different measures
of external impact
for this researcher.
They looked at publications,
a number of publications
in high profile
venues, citations
to those publications, success
at past European research
commission grant
proposals, and so forth.
And they put that on the x-axis.
And then on the y-axis, they
plotted the competence score.
And what we see here is that
if I pick a particular point
on the x-axis, a particular
value of the external impact
and I start to
move vertically, we
see that the typical
competence score for principle
investigators who were
men was significantly
higher than for women.
Or if I were to pick a
particular point on the y-axis
and I move horizontally,
then what I find
is that for a particular
competence score,
women as principal
investigators needed
significantly higher
measures of external impact
in order to achieve that.
And this was one of many studies
around this time that tried
this research methodology.
Find people who are
similar in the features
that they are presenting
to the decision
and are nonetheless getting
a very different outcome.
And thereby discovering some of
the ways in which this breaks
down along the lines of what the
law considers to be protected
attributes.
So this is an
illustration of human bias
in an empirical context.
Now when we move to
algorithms, and we consider
the idea of algorithms making
similar decisions that we might
train an algorithm to engage
in a predictive activity
to make a decision like this,
we face a different sort
of situation.
First, algorithms
in contrast humans,
have no direct incentives
to exhibit bias.
That's essentially
by definition.
The algorithm after
all knows really
in the end nothing
about the world.
It doesn't know who you are.
It's simply been
trained to optimize
this objective function.
Despite this, what we've
learned in the past
several years of
research is that there
are many sources of
potential bias in algorithms.
And we can try conceptually
to decompose these
into some constituent parts.
So for example, the choice
of label or objective
function that I'm trying
to predict, right?
The target of my prediction.
And we can see how
this might happen.
Suppose, for
example, that I were
trying to train an algorithm
to assign a competence
score in evaluating European
research commission grant
proposals.
I might feed it training data,
just the administrative data
of the administration of
this program over many years
what scores were assigned
to which grant proposals.
In the process, it would learn
to make these predictions,
and it might pick
up on, therefore,
the gender disparity that
was already in the data.
It's simply trying to faithfully
approximate the training data
that it's been given.
Similarly, we could see that
in the features which I handed,
right?
If I'm trying to have
it predict other things,
but one thing that I handed is
the so-called competence score
of the researcher,
then it essentially
has a feature that already
has that bias built into it.
These are the kinds of
points that we think about.
Now if we want to look at
sources of bias in algorithms,
then we face an
interpretability challenge.
We have to actually be able
to look into the algorithm
and try to understand
what's going on.
But a first point
I'd like to make
is that interpretability is not
only an issue for algorithms.
In fact, much of
discrimination law
is actually built, if you
think about it, with the idea
that human decision-making
is likewise
inscrutable and uninterpretable.
Because in the end,
the law actually
recognizes two categories
of discrimination.
This is in US
discrimination law where
the terminology is
disparate treatment
versus disparate impact.
Disparate treatment,
deliberately favoring
one applicant say that our
running example of something
like hiring, based
on a protected
attributes like race, gender,
national origin, religion,
or age.
And separately,
disparate impact,
the notion that
regardless of intent,
if a screening decision has a
disproportionate adverse effect
on a protected group,
then the burden of proof
shifts to the decision maker
to establish the business
necessity of their decision.
Such that if I
were hiring people
for a job that regularly
involved reaching things
in extremely high
places, then I might
want employees who were
taller, even if that
has a disproportionate adverse
effect based on gender,
for example.
But if I were hiring
software engineers,
and I put in a height
requirement, then
it'd be very, very hard
to justify that on grounds
of business necessity.
Now the point is, it can be
very hard to tell if a decision
maker has engaged in
disparate treatment
or in disparate impact.
And there are a few
reasons for this.
The most immediate is that
it's very hard to ask people,
they might lie.
They might be deceptive in the
evidence that they present.
But there's also
a deeper reason,
a reason coming from the
behavioral sciences, which
is they might genuinely
not know the rationale they
used for their decision.
Right?
And so there's
actually a long history
of work in the behavioral
sciences establishing
that when people provide
you with explanations
for their decisions,
those may or may not
be accurate renditions
of what actually
went into their decision.
How could we possibly know that?
Well some of this work
goes back to a series
of very creative experiments
done by Nisbett and Wilson
in the 1970s where they
would create lab situations,
ask people to make decisions.
And then with the
second group, they
would subtly change some
future of the environment,
get the decision to
change, and then ask people
why they made their decision.
And often people's
explanations had
nothing to do with the one
feature of the environment that
changed.
That's kind of abstract.
So let me make that very
concrete with an example
from one of their experiments.
One of their experiments, they
gave people a word recall task.
So they would ask people to
memorize a list of words,
recite it back, and
then at the end,
they would ask a non
sequitur question-- name
a brand of laundry detergent.
OK, in group B, they
would do the same thing.
But in the word recall to ask,
the words they would ask people
to memorize where things like--
beach, ocean, moon,
waves, sea, and so forth.
And then when they said name
a brand of laundry detergent,
many more people said Tide.
Now this is the
effect of priming.
Priming is that if I tell
you a bunch of words,
and then I ask you
to think of a word,
you often think of a word that's
right in the vicinity of all
those words by the process
of free association.
But Nisbett and Wilson
did one more step,
which was extremely clever.
They asked people, why did
you pick that brand of laundry
detergent?
And in both groups A
and B, both conditions
of the experiment,
people said it's
because it's the one my family
used when I was growing up.
It's what we use at home.
I remember the logo
from the store.
People in the
second group did not
say it's because you primed
me with a lot of words
that made me think of Tide.
Even though, statistically, we
know that many of those people
must have been
primed because there
was a big difference
in how many people
said Tide in the two groups.
So there are many other
Nisbett, Wilson experiments.
In a different
one, you ask people
to choose clothes from a rack.
You orient the rack to get them
to choose the one on the right
with high probability.
Yet, when people
are asked why they
chose the article
of clothing, they
mention the style or the
color, and not the fact
that you had oriented
things to essentially force
that one on them.
In other words, what's
essentially going on here
is that it's a set
of findings that
should make us think
a little harder
about the notion
of interpretability
and inscrutability as we
often apply it to algorithms.
Because it says although
people are always
happy to give you the
sense of an explanation,
they're always happy to say
this is why I did something.
The harder question is to know
whether that explanation is
correct.
In some sense, humans
in their own way
are inscrutable or black boxes
in their decision making.
We can't always know why
they did what they did.
And that we argue
actually presents
an interesting opportunity.
Beyond the question of whether
algorithms are increasing
or decreasing the
level of discrimination
in a particular situation,
which is an important question
that the field has
been thinking about,
we argue there's a
second question, which
is the ways in which well
regulated algorithms can
make discrimination
easier to detect.
The point being that
even an algorithm that's
extremely complex, trained
through an extremely
long pipeline of training with
very large amounts of training
data, despite all of that,
it has certain properties
that we can never expect
from human decision makers.
Obviously you know it's not
that we can simply read the code
and expect to understand
the algorithm.
There all sorts of reasons
ranging from the difficulty,
the cognitive difficulty of
reading code, to formal results
and undesirability
that tell us that.
But we can do some
things you could never
do with a human being.
You can for example,
if the algorithm is
available for inspection,
examine the objective function
that's being optimized.
Whereas with human
decision makers,
we can never really
ask somebody,
what is your objective function?
Think of all the situations
which you've been called on
to evaluate people, you
would have a hard time
writing down your formal
objective function
in that situation.
We can provide the algorithm
with counterfactuals.
We can say, here's
somebody who was evaluated.
I'm going to change
certain features,
and I'm going to run this
through the classifier
again and see if
the result changes.
Again, with a human
being, you could
ask somebody would you
have made the same decision
if this person had graduated
from school X instead of school
Y. And they might be even
in good faith attempt
to give you an answer
to that question.
But there's no way to really
know if that's actually
what they would have done.
So the point is,
algorithms aren't just
a change in accuracy, or scale,
or quantity relative to humans.
They're doing something
dramatically different.
They have an explicit
formal process
that they're following
with explicit features,
an explicit objective
function, something
that we can actually trace, even
if we can't follow the code.
And so we can prove them almost
as a natural experiment in ways
that we could never
do with human beings.
And so in this final couple
of minutes of the talk,
I wanted to ask
what kinds of things
might we learn if we can probe
an algorithm in this way?
And so I'll introduce
a bit of notation
to be able to talk about this.
But it leads to the observation
that this ways in which we
can decompose algorithmic bias
can actually be made formally
in a certain sense.
So how might we
make this formal?
Well let's think about a
machine learning pipeline.
And again, let's think about
the notion of a well regulated
algorithm, meaning that
the features, the training
process, the objective function
are available for inspection.
That's clearly crucial
in any of this analysis.
So we have individuals,
they have feature vectors.
We have something that the
screener is trying to optimize,
let's call it a
productivity function.
We're concerned about bias.
So we have an advantage
group, called it A,
and a disadvantage
group, let's call it D.
And finally, the frequency
of different feature vectors
in these populations
are different.
So the frequency of
feature vector X in group A
some function P of XA and
in group D it's P of XD.
So the point might be that
given the full feature vector X,
it doesn't matter what
group somebody comes from,
the advantage group or
the disadvantage group.
Because X contains
everything we need
to evaluates the
productivity function.
Nevertheless, there might be
a disparity between these two
groups, because of the
way those feature vectors
are distributed.
That A might have an abundance
of feature vectors conferring
high outcomes in the
screening process.
And D might have an abundance
of feature vectors conferring
lower outcomes.
So in particular, we could
compute the average value of F
in both group A group D.
Let's call that VA
of F and VD of F.
And we could look at now
what sociologists might call
the structural disadvantage.
Namely, D of F is now the
difference in averages.
It's the difference between
the average value in A
and the average value in D.
Now this is something
which precedes
the introduction of the output.
This was already
present in society.
And so while we might
want to use the algorithm
to remediate that, it's
important to realize
that is something that
predates the algorithm,
it's not a case, not a question
about what the algorithm has
added to the process.
Now the algorithm will
morph this function.
And so for any
function, not just F,
we might end up being
interested in disparity.
Let's call that D of W. So
the difference in averages
for any function [INAUDIBLE].
Now, let's think about the ways
in which the algorithm changes
this function as it goes.
So first of all, the
algorithm designer
is going to use a
function G instead of F,
because the real F is
not accessible to them.
So they're going to
use an approximation.
Second, the full
feature of vector X
is not accessible to them.
So they're going to use R and
R of X instead of the full X.
And finally, because
R of X is much shorter
than X, they're going to
use a transformed objective,
some shortened function H
composed with R instead of G.
And finally, there's going
be a training procedure that
produces a function
T instead of H.
So at the beginning, we had D of
F, the structural disadvantage.
But at the end of this
pipeline, we have D of T,
composed with R,
trained function
on the reduced representation.
And now, the final point
is that we actually
see that we can take this
disparity, the disparity in T
composed with R produced by
the machine learning algorithm
and break it into
these four components.
The structural disadvantage
that preceded the algorithm's
introduction,
followed by the bias
from the choice of outcome,
G instead of F. The bias
from the choice of
features, reduced
representation R
of X instead of X.
And finally, the bias from
the training procedure,
T instead of the true
approximate function H.
And so it actually says we
can, once we have access
to the pipeline, we can
actually do this decomposition.
And with that, I
wanted to wrap up.
Again, algorithms
are presenting us
with an interesting
opportunity, right?
Human decision
making contains bias.
As we've seen algorithmics
decision making contains bias.
But there's a certain
kind of detectability
of bias in algorthimic
decision making
that's really unprecedented
if we compare it
to human decision making.
That they contain
explicit ingredients
that allow us to attribute
components of the decision
to aspects of the
screening process.
This will only happen
with regulations in place
that allow us to examine the
machine learning pipeline.
But with that in place, it
really creates very interesting
opportunities going forward.
And one in which many fields are
going to have to play a part.
Thanks very much.
Thank you so much, Jon, for
the really insightful talk.
And one of the
things that struck me
was just the parallel use of
the term social technical gap,
from the intro and of
course from your talk here.
And one of the things
I love about your work
is that you're looking deeply
at the socio, the social side,
as well as investigating
particular formalisms that
can be deployed to either
explain or implement systems.
And so following that
line, one question
that I have relating
to your work
is that in your paper
on algorithmic fairness
that relates to a lot of
the topics you spoke about,
I was really struck by
your central argument which
is that the strategy of
blinding an algorithm to race
inadvertently detracts
from fairness.
And what that really reminds
me on the social side
is of Eduardo
[? Bunyah ?] Silva's work
on colorblind racism,
in which he describes
certain kind of frameworks that
relate to colorblind ideology,
and how it not only
detracts from fairness,
but actually discriminates.
So for him, that's
abstract liberalism,
naturalizing racist outcomes
like redlining, cultural
racism, minimizing of racism.
And so I just
wonder if you could
help to build a bridge from
your comments and your insights
about the limitations of
blinding algorithms to race
and the notion of
colorblind racism
and the way that might actually
implement particular types
of discrimination.
Yeah, thanks very much
for that question.
And I think it's
the kind of question
that I certainly look forward
to hearing the other panelists'
thoughts on as well, because I
think you definitely appreciate
being in this kind of
a conversation with so
many perspectives represented.
I think from the
computer science side,
I think we always need to be
careful about the ways in which
these issues of bias, for
example, come in through things
that we construct that we often
think of as part of the given
statement of the question.
So I thought your example at the
very beginning of the session
on recommender systems,
is one example of this.
I think any time that we
set up a ranking of people
or a clustering
of people, we have
to choose some
kind of objective.
What does it mean for
people to be similar?
And we often say we start
from this similarity metric
and then we put a lot of
work into the clustering
or the ranking.
But of course, obviously, a
huge and often untold number
of unstated assumptions
went into the construction
of that objective
function that we
take as given in the
statement of the question.
And so I think that's one
dimension of the gap that I
think we're all thinking
about, that there's been this
territory that, somehow, I think
each side of the discussion has
sometimes assumed that perhaps
the other one was somehow
trying to get under
control, and in fact wasn't.
That on the computer
science side,
we'll sometimes take the
problem formulation as a
given at some low level.
And then we'll work very hard
on extending it from there.
But of course, a lot of
that represented choices
that I think
incorporate the bias.
I think the same thing
happens again thinking
about the connection
to some of the things
you were saying in the
construction of features.
All of these systems, no system
is dealing with the person,
every algorithmic
system is dealing
with the representation.
And so I think the
choice of encodings
and the choice of
representation, which is again
I think very much in the theme
of some of the events going on
here is again
something that often
in the modeling of the problem,
people take that is given.
They say I'm going to
start from the fact
that you've represented
individuals.
You've represented applicants,
you've represented users.
You've represented
readers of the news.
All these things using a
certain collection of features
or at least some
kind of formalism.
And then I'll do the
best I can from there.
And so I think a
lot of the question
is to actually ask, where did
that representation come from?
What does that encode?
It makes sense.
I think it's such
a fascinating area
and we don't have a
lot of time before we
go to our next speaker.
But maybe just us planting
food for thought for later.
I feel like one of the
central dialogues we can--
points of dialogue we could
have within this panel
is about the essential
assumptions within each field.
And that sometimes
there is a sense--
so coming from computer
science myself as well,
and there can be a
sense that if you're
using algorithmic or
formless approaches,
then you're taking a
reductionistic approach
to society.
And I think what
your work shows is
that you can use formalisms
to address subjective issues
in ways that really provide
additional insight that
can be useful for those
subjective social issues
as well.
So I hope we can pick up
the point about the role
of formalization and
how it's not always
reductive and work such
as [INAUDIBLE] later.
Thanks.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
So--
Looking forward to that.
Thanks so much.
And so next up, we
have Behnaz Farahi
who will speak from a
different perspective and begin
and her reported talk
will provide insights
from an artistic point of
view, bringing together
our trifecta of sociology,
computer science, and the arts
in particular looking at
reflective and interpretive
issues around these
issues of bias in AI.
So let's begin
Behnaz's presentation.
We live in an age
where we are immersed
in the world of machine
learning algorithms, computer
vision, and biometric sensors.
But what does this all mean?
Why these computational
systems not replicate somewhat
disturbingly our
underlying biases
and serve to reinforce the
marginalization of those who
have typically been excluded?
Is AI necessarily complicit in
replicating human prejudice?
Or are there ways
of deploying AI
as a mean of
exposing human bias?
I would suggest that there
are potential strategies that
could be deployed for AI
to actually overcome bias.
In this presentation, I'm going
to address notions of the gaze,
surveillance, and ways of
seeing through the lens
of my own creative practice.
By implementing computer
vision technologies,
I hope to examine how different
strategies of the gaze
can be seen to undermine
various form of power structure
and to promote
forms of resistance.
Here I'm trying
to avoid any form
of technological determinism.
Rather than rehashing arguments
as to whether surveillance
is good or bad, I hope to take
an intersectional feminist
approach to show what constitute
the gaze and surveillance.
And to consider what the
strategies of resistance
might be prove to be effective
in art and design practices.
In my work, I have used various
computer vision technologies
to enhance human perception.
For example, this is
an emotive wearable
which can recognize and respond
to the facial expressions
of people around, the
different type of behaviors.
This type of smart,
soft, robotic garment
could potentially
benefit those with autism
who have difficulties
recognizing facial expressions.
Another work, [INAUDIBLE],,
is an emotive collar
equipped with a facial tracking
camera, an array of rotating
quills, which respond to
the movement of onlookers
and their facial expressions.
Similar to how a
blind person could
sense through
haptic information,
the movement of the wearable
would allow the wearer to sense
where people were standing
and the emotions they're
expressing even with
their eyes closed.
Here, I hope to address
two questions related
to the notion of the gaze.
Firstly, what does it
mean to be observed?
Secondly, what do we see when
we look out at the world?
Through my argument, I use
gaze as an interchangeable
concept, which could be shared
between human and machine.
This take us to the historical
concept of panopticon.
The panopticon refers to a
type of institutional building
and a system of
control envisioned
by English philosopher, Jeremy
Bentham in 18th century.
The layout of the
panopticon allows a guard
to observe occupants without
them knowing whether or not
they're being watched.
French philosopher,
Michel Foucault,
revitalizes interest in
the panopticon in his 1975
book, Discipline and Punish.
And uses it to
illustrate such a model
could be applied to
disciplinary societies
in order to control
their citizens.
He described a prisoner
of a panopticon
as being at the receiving end
of asymmetrical surveillance.
As a consequence, the
inmate polices himself
for fear of punishment.
What is fascinating about this
example is that rather than
external actions, the
gaze of the watcher
is internalized
to such an extent
that each prisoner become
his or her own watch person.
Similarly, we could
argue that this
is what allows rules and
regulation to be internalized
so as to inform our
actions, behaviors,
and even our beliefs.
Moreover, the manner in which
we naturalize and internalize
rules, it could be
claimed cause a society
to be less willing to
contest unjust laws,
and accept a dominant outlook.
Similar to how the inmates
are not aware whether or not
they're being watched,
we are not aware
that we have been
controlled through
naturalized dominant rules
rooted in our own culture.
This internalized
asymmetrical power structure
could be seen in the
notion of male gaze.
In her essay on Visual
Pleasure and Narrative Cinema,
Laura Mulvey exposes
the asymmetry
of social and political
power relations
between men and women.
Mulvey claims that
the male gaze serves
to depict women as
the object of pleasure
for the heterosexual
male viewer.
Besides the fact that
women are regularly
subject to sexual harassment
whenever they enter
public space through various
forms of looked-edness
women have absorbed
all this unconsciously
as a form of
internalized male gaze.
What if women were
to subvert this
through the power of their gaze?
Could we draw up in
computer vision technologies
to allow women to know when
onlookers are staring at them?
Augmented with facial
and gaze tracking
technology in smart
materials, this cape
responds to the onlookers' gaze.
The project engages with
broader social issues
such as the male gaze
on the female body.
The facial tracking
algorithm in this piece
detects age, gender, and
gaze of the onlooker.
While we know that
gender is performative
and it doesn't depend
on pure representation,
the movement of the garment
based on the viewer's gaze
could unfold in new
sets of social meanings.
If you are the wearer, you
know which parts of your body
is being looked at.
And if you are an onlooker,
you know that your action
has been noticed.
The aim is to see how
different strategies could
be used to undermine
the patriarchal system
by developing form of resistance
using surveillance technology.
I wonder what do we see as
we gaze out to the world?
As a thought experiment, French
psychoanalysis, Jacques Lacan,
invites us to envision ourselves
before a female mantis.
The female mantis is known
for devouring his partner
after sex.
In Lacan's experiments,
we're wearing a mask
and we do not know whether
the mask represent us
as a female or male.
And therefore, we don't
know whether or not
we will be eaten by
the female mantis.
We simply do not know
what we are to the other.
And we often project our
own very biases to the other
in order to
understand the other.
In fact, we don't see
anyone as they are.
Rather we see them as we are.
And how we are is
informed by the conformity
to many of behavioral
assumptions dictated
by laws and customs.
Although the colonial
racist and sexist gaze
might project oppression,
backwardness, and terrorism
onto the image of Muslim
woman wearing a burka,
I would like to stress
the inherent difference
between a mask and masquerade.
While the mask hides,
the masquerade reveals.
But perhaps we could
suggest that both
are acting to some extent as
a shield against the intrusive
gaze.
This project is inspired
by the historical mask
worn by Bhandari
women from South Iran.
Has been said that this
mask were developed
during Portuguese colonial
rule as a way of protecting
the wearer from the gaze
of a slave master looking
for pretty women.
From these Iranian
masks protecting women
from the patriarchal oppression,
to mask off Northwest Coast
Indians, to mask worn
as political statements,
mask take on a range of
different religious, social and
political roles.
And offer an interesting
insight into how
we could use them to
either conceal or reveal
our identities.
While these Iranian
masks cover most
of the wearer's
face except the eye,
I've been wondering how the eyes
could be used as an expressive
medium for communication.
In my research, I came across
an interesting incident
in which an American
officer uses blinking
to send a secret message.
In this video, you're seeing
Admiral Jeremiah Denton
blinking the word torture using
Morse code during his captivity
in the Vietnam.
Do you think that [INAUDIBLE]?
No, I don't know
what is happening.
But whatever the position
of my government is,
I support it, fully.
Whatever the position
of my government is,
I believe in it, yes sir.
I am a member of
that government.
The use of code for
communication is nothing new.
And in fact, women came
up with a code word
has a method for
reporting domestic abuse
during this lockdown.
In this project,
I was particularly
inspired by a recent
experiment involving two AI
bots at the Facebook AI lab.
The intention was to
monitor how two bots might
develop a dialogue.
However, during this
experiment, a bot seemingly
started to formulate their
own language, a language
that no human could understand.
The researchers had to intervene
and tweak the algorithms
to prevent this from happening.
The story could also reveal
how knowledge is power,
and an ability to
understand unnerves
those who wish to
maintain their authority.
For the source text
of this project,
I use the seminal article,
Can the Subaltern Speak?
by the feminist
theorist, Gayatri Spivak.
She asked whether it might
be possible for the colonies
or the subaltern to
have a voice in the face
of colonial oppression?
Using machine
learning algorithm,
we can use Markov
chain to create a text.
We represent each words as
a state and view transitions
as the likelihood
that the specific word
might go after another.
We can consider these states
either a word or character
level.
And we can analyze
what the probability
might be of a given letter
appearing after three letters.
The engrams of a given
text provides a strategy
for generating the next text.
The Markov chain could
be therefore used
to generate text where
each new letters is
dependent upon the
previous letters.
As the mass communicates
using BLE protocol,
the algorithm is repeated
and the engrams changes.
The smaller the engram
gets, the less meaning
there is in the
generated text from
the linguistic perspective.
This letter generated
through this process
is translated into Morse
code, which informs
the movement of the actuators.
In the video documentation
of this project, which
will be shown
shortly, you will see
two women wearing masks, covered
with eyelashes controlled
by AI.
They begin to communicate
with each other,
blinking their eyelashes
in rapid succession.
The aim is to develop
a secret message
for transmitting information
between multiple women.
The project brings together
design, critical thinking,
feminism, and AI.
Winston Churchill once
said, "We shape our tools,
and thereafter our
tools shape us."
But doesn't this suggest a form
of technological determinism?
After all, there is no inherent
application for any tool.
The knife could be
used as a murder weapon
or just as a tool
for cutting an apple.
Similar arguments could be
made about surveillance.
The question we should
ask are, in what context?
How and for whom
are we using it?
We should be aware of
potential problems with AI.
For once an issue is recognized
as problem that becomes
a different kind of problem.
It becomes a problem, not
by which we are trapped,
but rather with
which we can deal.
Bias is certainly
a problem which
originates from human
beings and is replicated
and even exacerbated in AI.
As we are training the
artificial algorithms
to learn to see the world, it
is important to ask ourselves
what does it mean to
be seen by the machine?
And through the lens
of what kind of data
are they trying to
look out to the world?
So Thanks so much, Behnaz for
the fascinating, creative,
and evocative talk.
And one of the things that your
talk brought to mind for me
was that you're
looking both at issues
that are implemented and
instantiated by the machine.
So the gaze of the machine
that really surveillance
technologies and so forth, as
well as the human phenomena
that you're
discussing and putting
into dialogue with critical
theory and the arts.
And so I was struck
by one phrase
early on in your talk
where you mentioned
about resistivity strategies
against these kind of issues,
whether it's a objectifying
gaze or other forms
of discriminatory surveillance.
And so you mentioned that
certain resistive strategies
can be proved to be effective
in art and design practices.
And so I wonder
just for you, what
does it mean for a
resistive strategy
to be proved effective in
art and design practice?
Thank you so much for the
great question, folks.
And also before I
answer, I want to say
that this is a great honor to
be in such an inspiring line
up of speakers.
I'm honored to be here.
To answer your question, I think
especially from art and design
perspective, I'm
particularly interested
in ways that we can use
various computational systems
and repurpose those in order
to bring a new sort of insight
or in a way subvert certain
dominant assumptions that we
have, either through
our culture or
through technological
assumptions that we have.
So it's always this having
a hand on the technology
and in order to
subvert it in a way.
In particular, I would say
I'm really inspired also
by the work of other artists,
such as Christoph [? Fadusco ?]
and his notion of interrogative
design, in which we really
look at design as a way
of addressing larger
social, political,
cultural issues.
And so in my case,
particularly I'm
interested to use a
lot of computer vision
technologies embedded in
the substrate of the matter,
and see that how
materials could be
intelligence and smart enough.
But also to address
larger issues
in order to empower
those that for instance
in the latest project, the
women that they were oppressed
or oppressed under
colonial oppression,
how we can empower those
through the use of technology.
So it's always bringing
technology and repurposing it,
and give it a certain
twist for envisioning what
the future would look like.
Thanks so much for
the elaboration.
And maybe if we continue
down the same path
in the same phrase, there is
the particular word of proof.
And so for a
researchers such as Jon,
proof has a very
particular kind of meaning.
And a researcher
such as Ruha might
use a term such
as a demonstrate,
depending on the kind of
work that she is doing.
And so in work we are building
evocative objects maybe
to spark critical reflection.
Does proof mean that
something like you
can demonstrate that
people think critically
after engaging with this work?
Or is there something else
that you're aiming for?
So again, what does
it, in some sense,
what does it mean to prove
within the domain in which you
operate?
I think a lot of time,
perhaps it's bringing
a new type of questions.
So it's bringing a new
sort of what if questions.
What if women were
able to experience
the gaze of others
on their as they're
entering the public space?
I think bringing this type
of provocative questions
and creating conversations, and
sharing this work with others,
and it creates I would say an
escape or a sort of imagination
for how we can really reuse or
repurpose these technologies
in a novel way that
reflect on critical issues
on issues related either to
feminism or critical studies.
And I'm really interested to see
how the world of design and art
could learn from
those disciplines.
And combine and merge
them together in order
to empower those communities.
Thanks, I really love this
idea that we're describing.
The role of the arts
not to answer questions,
but to provoke questions.
And through those
questions, people
can better understand the
operations of these kind
of systems that impose bias.
And to provoke those kind of
questions, then imagination,
aesthetics, culture,
subjectivity,
all of those kind of issues
within the realm of the work
that you're doing become crucial
for that kind of practice.
So I really appreciate
the kind of insights
that you've brought.
And it's also a kind
of segue because now we
have all of the panelists
that together in some time
to engage in
questions as a group.
And so I would like just
to begin to transition
into those questions.
And maybe pick up with one
that came up earlier, again,
my question with Jon
that he mentioned,
maybe that would be a great
thing to talk about as a panel.
And what the observation
was, it was this idea
that in Jon's work,
he's showing that
a particular type of a
system, if you, in that case,
blind the algorithms to race.
But if you blind it any
particular kind of social issue
that relates to
discrimination, then you
could inadvertently
detract from fairness.
And then the other
thing that I mentioned
was that in the social
sciences that the idea
of colorblind
racism, which seems
to have a very strong
parallel to this kind
of algorithmic insight.
And so maybe to begin, I could
ask Ruha the same question.
So what is your
take on reconciling
this idea that computationally
blinding algorithms from race
detracts from fairness,
and then socially
colorblindness also
detracts from fairness
or even more encodes racism?
So can you just
elaborate on what you see
coming from that connection?
Can you restate
the question a bit?
It's a little hard for me to
get at what you're asking.
Sure, I'd be happy to.
Yes, so it's really
just reconciling,
I think, a similar insight
coming from two points of view.
And so in computer
science, the idea
is that when you
look at fairness
through the lens
of that estimation
approaches, the
objective functions, even
formal definitions.
Within that domain,
then Jon has found
that blinding an algorithm to
race detracts from fairness.
And I know that that's also
an idea within sociology
from another perspective.
The idea that colorblindness
that is blinding or ignoring
the role of race also
detracts from fairness.
And so I'd ask if
you could elaborate
on that from your lens as well.
That kind of role of obscuring
an issue such as race
and the way that, that can end
up detracting for fairness.
Yeah I certainly can.
So it is true and you cited
Bonilla-Silva and others
where it just comes down
to this faulty notion
that ignoring something
makes it go away.
And really, it's just a way
of delaying thought or action
around it.
Now something I want
to put in conversation
with this idea of
colorblind racism
is that paying
attention to things,
collecting data on
issues that oftentimes we
and moving away from
ignoring, assume
that simply producing knowledge,
or highlighting, or exposing
certain issues to the use
of data and various tools,
is itself a solution.
And an idea that I write
a little bit about in Race
After Technology is this
notion of the datafication
of injustice.
That is to say that we are often
asking questions about issues
that we should or we could
already have the answers to.
That is to say we're
producing more and more data
and knowledge about
problems that we know
exist, in some cases that
we know how to tackle,
and that there's not the
social and political will
to deal with.
And so I want to put on the
table this idea that, yes,
ignoring let's say racism
and other forms of inequality
is certainly stands in
the way of social change
and transformation.
But sometimes too, the call for
more and more data and exposure
of issues can also
be a delaying tactic
to acting on what
we already know.
And so that's a different
way of complicating
the notion of paying
attention to issues
is not a straightforward
solution.
It can actually stand in the
way of making change as well.
Thanks so much for the point.
And I saw Jon
nodding as you speak.
So could you maybe also
respond to Ruha's notion
that sometimes data
collection or even big data
could be seen as
a stalling tactic,
or even just even if
not intentionally could
have that kind of effect?
And then also, it may be
related to your notion
of algorithmic fairness to the
kind of sociological notion
that Ruha has just described.
Sure, yeah.
Thanks for those points,
and thanks Ruha for the--
I think those are
very important things
to keep in mind that there
is this continuum where
obviously not paying attention
to things poses these problems.
But that there could be a
point where we have essentially
what you said, we've
collected data,
we're aware of the problem.
And what we need next is
not more data collection
or more intensive
analysis of that.
I mean, a couple of things
that seem interesting
here is one, the level of scale.
So there's collecting data
about the aggregate nature
of the problem.
That we recognize
there's a policy change
that needs to be made.
We have ample evidence for that.
And then there's
collecting nature
about the individual problem in
a particular instance, right?
So for example, if
a person believes
that their particular
workplace is engaging
in discriminatory behavior,
even if we have enormous data
about the aggregate
effects of discrimination,
we may not have much
data about the effect
in their particular
place of work.
That's a situation where
as these systems become
more quantitative,
we have the potential
to turn the argument from one
that might have been present
four decades ago where
it now comes down
to a qualitative estimation of
what the environment there was,
what the decision making was.
Where we may have much
more detailed traces
of the level of the individual.
Now detailed traces of the
level of the individual I
think it's been interesting
in all three of the talks
that we saw that there's this
interesting tension that it
brings up both concerns as
we collect this information.
But it can also be used
as a source of power
for someone who potentially
is affected by these.
I was certainly very
interested the relation
in the third talk
about some of the ways
in which these technologies
can be used on both sides.
But so I think the aggregate
versus the individual,
it's interesting.
I also think it's a
very interesting point
about the collecting more
data can be a stalling
tactic, because it's interesting
I think how widespread that
certainly can be in
computer science.
Though if we choose areas, of
course, I don't want to say.
Even if we choose quite
different areas within computer
science, and I don't
want to say anything
that would be controversial
for my colleagues
in cryptography and security.
But I think one tension
that comes up there
in a very different context
is that there are systems
that we know are insecure.
And there comes a
point where people say,
we want more attacks
on these systems
to demonstrate their insecurity.
What we need is a
more principled way
of building them.
And so I think often what
we have is the collection,
the enumeration of
problems at some point
need to give way to the
articulation of more
principal solutions.
Thanks so much.
And what you meant,
so Jon mentioned
in his talk about the role of
policy in terms of solutions,
and then Ruha just mentioned
the kind of issue of now
that there are some of these
kind of questions around bias
when which there is an
immense amount of wisdom,
and strategizing,
and history already.
And so the next
question is for Behnaz,
which is, what do you
see as the role of art
and design then for maybe
influencing policy makers
or for instantiating some
of the kind of practices
that we already know
well from other domains?
How can art and
design play a role
in these kind of processes?
Yeah, I think it's a great
question and in terms of I
think developments of some
sort of ethical guidelines
would be obviously
one way to start.
But also, I really think
especially for art and design,
I think one of the important
aspects of that is education.
What I'm extremely
excited about is
to teach next
generation of designers
to be able to not look at the
systems as sort of black box
that they have no clue how
it works, but they actually
understand how it works, how
they can train their own data
sets, how they can understand
AI system as something that they
can tinker, and prototype,
and repurpose them.
And don't wait for the
big, large corporates
to dictate what is the
future of technology.
But we actually take active
role in participating,
in shaping the conversation
around the technology.
So that's what I think that I
really hope that in general, we
see in education a
system in art and design,
particularly to really
the notion of literacy.
Coming from Iran and
knowing that sometimes it
can be difficult to have access
to knowledge and education
or limited access, I
think it's very important
to open this borders,
and open the knowledge,
and share knowledge
as much as possible.
If people know how AI
system, how computer vision
technology works, and
they start tinkering
with these technologies,
that would empower them
and would empower, and open up
new possibilities for the world
of art and design.
So I'm extremely excited
about that possibility.
Thanks so much.
And one of the things
that you mentioned
in your talk and
the Q&A afterwards
was the role of the imagination.
And so what you bring to
mind our work such as Octavia
Butler's, Kindred, Joanna
Russ', The Female Man,
or Ralph Ellison's,
Invisible Man.
So works that you
could say from one lens
are all within speculative--
the domain of speculative
fiction that actually think
are some of the great
sociological treatises
of our time in the last century.
Precisely because they
can evoke and change minds
through metaphor and other
types of interpretive means,
not only through quantitative
or qualitative studies even.
So the next question will be one
that comes from the audience.
And I think this
one will go to Jon.
It's is it possible to find
or create truly unbiased data?
And if not, how do we
avoid imbuing any data
with our own implicit biases?
Yeah, obviously
a great question.
And I don't think one that
there's a simple answer to.
But I mean, I think
if you were going
to make the argument
that there really
is no such thing
as unbiased data,
I think you would start
from the observation
that it's in the
nature of computation
to work inside an abstraction.
I mean, I think that's both
the power in the limitation
of the computational approach.
As computer
scientists, were taught
to create abstraction barriers
between the world, which
is very complicated in the
system that we're building,
the system that
we're working in.
And so I think, and that
again gives computer science--
I think abstraction
barriers [INAUDIBLE]
technological systems
much of their power.
There are many examples
of this, right?
The fact that you can in
non pandemic times perhaps
fly into an airport,
rent a car, and start
driving that car
down the highway,
a dangerous, potentially
life threatening activity.
It's a car you've
never seen before.
You have no idea how
the engine works,
but because it presents to you
the abstraction of a steering
wheel, a gas pedal,
and a brake pedal,
you're able to put
your life in its hands
even though you've
never seen it before.
So abstraction is an
incredibly powerful thing.
But abstraction is
extremely reductive, right?
The car might be a hybrid car.
It might be some new
high-tech kind of engine.
We don't really
know how it works.
It's a similar way I
think any act of building
a computational model is
that same kind of reduction.
And so there's going to
be design decisions that
go into that.
I think that's the
sense in which data will
be inevitably imbued with bias.
I think now this is
the part of the answer
that I think is in some ways
more aspirational than concrete
at the moment.
But I think one of
the things I think
is promising in the kinds of, in
the way research has been going
over the past several years
is the really rapidly widening
scope of the conversation around
the construction of data sets,
the construction of
computational models
to understand both
the computer science
side and outside the
computer science.
That this is a
first order activity
that everyone needs
to participate in.
That this is not
inside any one field.
And I think that
I think is going
to be a way to at least
begin making progress.
Thanks so much.
So if I can just insert
a couple of my own views,
and then I'll have
the next question,
which is for Ruha Benjamin.
So I just wanted
to say something,
because my book,
Phantasmal Media,
An Approach to Imagination,
Computation, and Expression,
was on the screen.
I saw it before I spoke.
The central idea is that while
people often think of computing
as objective, utilitarian, and
acultural, actually computing
implements various
forms of subjectivity
is always cultural, and can
be used to spark criticality.
And so I didn't write--
this was from a while ago
before the term algorithmic bias
was quite in parlance.
But one of the key ideas was
that all technical systems
are cultural systems.
And just as an
example, even something
like the stored program
of architecture,
the [INAUDIBLE]
machine, it's in all,
nearly every computing
system we use
is grounded in the
culture of its time.
If you go back and read
the original paper,
it's not abstracted like
the way we describe now.
It describes inputs and
outputs, "Organs of machines"
and it says computers should
be made of vacuum tube
elements, and all of
these other things
that we have left
by the wayside that
are entirely rounded
within its time period
and cultural history.
And so I think
it's just something
we need to be aware of is
that even systems we think
of as most objective
and acultural
implement various
forms of culture.
And so the question
that I have for Ruha,
I think it was sparked by
something that Benhaz said,
but I think that it resonates
with your talk as well, which
is about tools of resistance.
So Benhaz spoke about
artistic tools of resistance.
The question is broader.
And I think it's
relevant for you
because you talk
about communities
and how communities can
resist against certain types
of technologies
that impose bias.
And so the question is, are
tools of resistance ones that
cannot be co-opted by
those being resisted?
And if I can add, are tools
that cannot be co-opted even
possible?
So anyway, that's my question.
I appreciate that.
And just before
I jump into this,
I also wanted to build
on something else
Benhaz was saying
about the role of art,
the arts in terms of
our ethical framework.
And I would say in terms of our
imagination, one of the things
that I really want to insist
upon is that the arts shouldn't
be an afterthought, it
shouldn't be something
that we bring in after the
algorithms are designed
or after the technical
system in order
to create a sheen or a gloss.
But really to understand that
imagination is a battlefield.
And that in terms
of imagination,
certain imaginations
are being codified
in our technical systems.
And one of the ways to
understand the role of the arts
is to radically
expand our imagination
through the questions
that are asked,
through the different
frameworks that are brought
to bear ethical and otherwise.
And so again, to understand
the centrality of imagination
and everything that we're
doing, not simply in the realm
that are dubbed the arts.
And so that's
something I just want
to put on the table, which
relates to this idea of tools.
I don't think there
are any tools that
are immune from co-optation.
But what I would
suggest is that in terms
of trying to prevent that
understanding, that tool
making, one it doesn't just
apply to hardware and software.
So one of the things that I
really want us to consider
are the many types of social
tools, tools of interaction
relationality that don't
usually come to mind when
we say the word technology.
And so to have a much more
expansive understanding of what
counts as tools, and
to understand that
in terms of the power, the way
that power is laden in tools,
it's not a one-time
thing where you
at the point of
creation of something
that it sets it off in
a certain trajectory.
Either we're helping
the oppressed
or empowering certain groups.
But it's an ongoing battle.
It's an ongoing
form of resistance.
And so in that
case, I don't think
that there's a way to immunize
any of our technologies
from co-optation
or from being used
in ways that were not intended.
And so that's why we have
to build into the process,
form some accountability
where we continually calibrate
and think about how
and if these tools
are being used to reinforce the
status quo, reinforce power,
and inequality or being used to
subvert it and to transform it.
And so it really has to
be an ongoing process
of accountability that's
institutionalized that's not
simply left to individuals
who may or may not
have good intentions.
I think the stakes are too high.
To think of the
issues that we're
wrestling with on
this panel simply
in terms of ethics, or the
ethics of individuals, or even
fields.
But we really have
to build and creative
ecosystem, forms of
regulation, accountability,
protections that operate
whether or not individuals
have the best intentions.
I think we can't rest our, build
our futures on the well-meaning
intent not to do harm,
as important as that is.
So what I love in
your response are,
well, I was going
to say two things.
But actually all of
it, but two things
I'll call attention
to in particular
were one, this idea about
computing as a tool.
It's a very instrumental
view of computing,
because computing can be
used in so many broader ways.
Whether it's purely
for the austere
beauty of formalization.
Or it could be something such
as in some of the communities
that I work in, seeing the
computer as a medium, not just
as a tool.
So when you ask that question,
can media be co-opted?
Then it becomes a little bit
more obvious than when you say,
can a tool be co-opted?
And then finally,
well, the reason
I wanted to bring this
together with the second point
that you made was about the
arts not being an afterthought.
Because I think
oftentimes that comes
from when the arts are seen
in an instrumental way.
And so let's say if someone's
applying for a National Science
Foundation grant,
and then say, OK, I
have my intellectual merit.
Arts will be broader impact,
I'll bring in an artist
afterwards and they can help
me to submit dissemination.
When arts are thought of
in that instrumental way,
it often leads to them being
that kind of afterthought.
And so the next question
is for Behnaz, which is,
I think related to this
idea of an instrumental view
of technologies being co-opted.
And so the question is
asking about your thoughts
around gender that
stem from your work,
and the way that
your work operates
as a critique of
heteronormativity
of heterosexual normativity.
But they're also
wondering about the ways
that heterosexual normatively
might be reinforced
by this kind of work.
And then they ask know how
a gender fluid perspective
on the issue of
gaze or prospective
influenced by queer theory might
inform your work differently.
And then just as the
final editorial remark
on their question, because we
talked about deep learning.
With deep state
technologies, the major way
that they're being used,
the most prevalent use
is actually sexual
objectification,
like you mentioned.
In fact, creating nude pictures
of celebrities and so forth.
That's the most prevalent use
of those technologies out there,
which seems very related to
this idea of a sexualizing gaze.
So what would the lenses of
gender fluidity and queer
theory bring to the kind
of work that you do?
Well that's a difficult one.
But I'll try to answer
as best as I can.
So it's fascinating
because, for instance,
in [INAUDIBLE] of the
gaze, the project that
attract the gaze
of the onlooker,
I was using a system
that it was pre-trained.
I was using a pre-trained model
that it was basically able to
or predicting the gender
in a very binary way.
Which we know is
very problematic
if there is a male or a female.
So as a designer, although
I use both systems
that they are trained
based on pre-trained data
or in some cases, I train the
system with a certain data.
I think it's fascinating
to just address
these issues and particularly
as you mentioned regarding
let's say, gender fluidity.
Can computational
system really predict
through the pure representation
or identification?
And I think folks from
that point of view,
your work particularly
actually address these issues
that how our identity
is being represented
in virtual environments.
And I think a lot
of times, for me,
is to either use them
or question them.
I think also I have to
mention that this notion
of essentialism, which is very
dominant in feminist discourse.
Could we actually
say that there is
anything essential
about being a female
and having the
female experience?
Obviously, it's been in
Western way of thinking.
And there are many
theories that question
that sort of essentialism
in art and design practices.
Having said that, also I have
to acknowledge that coming
from a culture that it's
mainly male dominance,
you are still struggling with
a lot of this gender binary
differences.
So I don't have a answer how
computational systems could
address the gender fluidity,
because it's absolutely
a complicated topic, but I
think it's also very, very
interesting to think
about how are we going
to represent our identities?
So I would like to also
hear from you folks.
What are your thoughts on that?
Sure, and so speak
briefly and then
I have another question for Jon.
And so one, is trying to
reconcile between domains by,
so I mentioned the computer
science [INAUDIBLE],,
I also have degrees
in art as well.
And so one of the
things I have to do then
is think about the values
within each domain.
So is it something
like generalizability?
Is it a value like how
exhaustive and efficient
is this particular
algorithm that I've created?
Or is it something like
can the system spark
criticality and within society?
Or can it even be
used practical?
And can you-- this
is maybe more like
some of the work in
the social sciences.
Can you demonstrate that
this work empirically sparks
reflection, say using some
kind of validated instrument?
And so when reconciling
between those
domains, then I
often find insights
such as when
critiquing a system,
let's say a computer
science system that
was created to help
girls learn mathematics,
then they can ask questions such
as, but what model of gender
is this system working under?
Is this a biological
positivist model
of gender in which all
girls are assumed to learn
in the same kind of way?
Or is it something where their
girlhood is not necessarily
understood to be something
which is monolithic across them?
So then you can interrogate
the technical practices
in a very different
way when you begin
to think about how
it's instantiating
particular sets of values.
And so I think what you were
mentioning in particular,
I have one patented
computational system,
which is for
representing identity
very differently than
in the top-down way
many computational systems do.
It's essentially not trying
to put you into a box
by some set number of fields.
But actually
implements fluidity,
that is you have a trajectory
in which you naturalize
into categories, the
[INAUDIBLE] of membership
in categories,
multiple categories.
So your identity isn't fixed
at any one particular location.
And it can be applied to so
many different things, ranging
from music, because
our tastes might
be different in the morning
than in the evening.
Or some of the kind
of issues of bias
that we've spoken about
in conversation here.
I'll leave it at that.
And maybe could continue later.
But I would want to just--
Maybe I can just one
more thing, folks?
Sure.
That this somehow we
are complicit in this.
I mean, the fact that
we already have LGBTQ.
We have this form of
identification that at the end,
people have to put
themselves in the boxes
to identify as one
of those categories.
This would sort of originates
from that point of view,
and then replicates in
our computational systems.
So my point is
that it's the issue
is so complex because in our
actual way that we are also
identifying the society,
we are constantly creating
these boxes that you mentioned.
And we add more categories.
And we think that by
adding more categories,
everyone should find
their own identification.
But we truly have to
question how we operate, even
in the society in
the first place,
rather than how the
system also replicate
in computational systems.
Right, that's exactly right.
I mean, I use that
term box effects
to describe all the kind
of discriminatory fallout
that comes from that kind
of taxonomic perspective
on identity.
And maybe more evocatively,
Jeff [? Valcore ?] and Lee
[? Star ?] the term
identity torque,
this idea that when you
don't fit into those identity
categories being
forced by society,
it actually produces
torque on the individual.
That is , actual emotional pain
because people have experiences
that they can't reconcile
with how they see themselves.
And so there's so much
more we can say about this.
But such important points.
And so one question that
we have from the audience,
actually from Will
Lockett who was
one of the coorganizers of
the Unfolding Intelligence
Symposium asked about the
capacity of mathematics
to represent.
So I'll use his terms,
and then also say the way
that I interpret it,
which is the capricious
specificity of
individual behavior
as in some agent
based simulation.
And I think really it's very
similar to the first question
that I asked.
Actually the ending
question in the Q&A
after Jon's session,
which was, is computing,
is using mathematical approaches
always going to be reductive?
Or is there some way
that those approaches
can be used that are
complementary to other types
of approaches, and are not
necessarily going to be
reductive in harmful ways?
Yeah, it's a great question.
And I mean, I think it's
a question that comes up
a lot when we talk about
building mathematical models
of the world.
And I think in particular,
mathematical models
of the social world.
And know it already
begins with the fact
that a lot of people's
education trains them
in the intuitions around
building mathematical models
of simple physical systems.
And there's always
this optimistic sense
that maybe I can take
what I learned there
and begin to apply it to the
situations in the social world.
And obviously, we've run into
an enormous number of challenges
there.
In particular, that
the state of the world,
in the case of the social world,
typically has an extremely long
description, right?
In the language of features,
it's extremely wide.
There are many, many
different things
that I know about an individual,
what their experiences are,
what their actions are, what
their motivations and intent
are.
And as a result
to represent that,
it's something where
we can't really
hope to fully either know or
represent all those things.
And that's why I think we end up
with some of these challenges.
So I think I personally
tend toward optimism
that this is an activity that
we should be engaging in,
because I think it's
a valuable supplement
to the kinds of discussions
which are taking place.
But we certainly I don't
think see any evidence
that it's a substitute for
these other forms of analysis.
I think it supplements it.
And if we think of
it as a supplement,
then we can begin to look
for ways in the spirit
that I think has been
true in all the talks.
I think Benhaz,
that you [INAUDIBLE]
very powerfully the multiple
uses of the same tool
or the same methodology to look
for ways in which reductiveness
can sometimes
expose commonalities
across situations that we
think of as very different.
And I think if that's
done in partnership
with the conversation that
recognizes the differences
across these
domains, then it can
establish linkages
that may actually
provoke further thinking.
I think if it's done to in the
absence of that conversation,
then it just ends up obscuring
important distinctions.
Thanks, it reminds
me of a statement
made by the late great computer
scientist, Joseph Gogan, who
said something to the
effect of, we can describe
subjective social phenomena in
subjective ways, critical ways.
And we can also describe them in
precise ways, and it doesn't--
none of these it gives
additional authority
to the analysis.
They're just different languages
for doing the analysis.
And so when you
say complementary,
I feel like that's
one of the keys,
just understanding whether it's
the imaginative like Behnaz's
and Ruha's work as well,
because I've seen her work
bridge with the arts, too.
Or the mathematical, it's
just different lenses
that, again, can be
complementary in addressing
related issues.
And so I want to
also just, since we
have just a few
more minutes left,
ask if any of the panelists
have questions for one another.
I'll take the opportunity, not
necessarily to pose a question,
but just to be in conversation.
And two quick things.
One is on your last
point, Fox, about and also
Jon's point about
the complementary,
I want us to think
about that in relation
to the very real hierarchies
of knowledge in the academy
that while ideally these
fields would be complementary,
there are certain
forms of knowledge that
have more, that are granted more
authority and more legitimacy.
That even in collaboration,
trump other forms of knowledge.
And they follow along
predictable lines,
hard to soft, the qualitative
to quantitative, et cetera.
And at the same
time, I just want
to say that we've
spent some time talking
about the relationship
between computation
and reductive racist,
sexist, forms of hierarchy.
But I also want to call my
own fields into complicity
the social sciences
and the humanities,
and that storytelling can be
just as violent, and just as
reductive in terms of
infusing all kinds of meaning
in the world.
So it's not simply
on the statistical
or the computational side
that this kind of reckoning
needs to happen, but also in the
humanities and social sciences
that have been some
of the major producers
of this racist architecture
that we still inhabit.
And so no field is
immune from the kind
of questions and reckoning that
I think we're talking about.
Such important points.
They both come to mind this
notion of cultural humility,
which often is not used related
to academic disciplines.
But I think you give an
exact, a good description
of why it should be applied
to those such disciplines.
And so we're coming down to
just our last seconds here.
So I appreciated
that final remark
in terms of bringing
the different ideas
into conversation
with one another.
I would like just to welcome
if Jon and then Behnaz have
just very brief
closing remarks too,
then we can do so and
then end the panel.
I first of all, I would
say it's been a privilege
to be able to take part in the
conversation with all of you
and with the insights
that have been expressed
across different fields.
And Fox, thanks very
much for your moderation
of the panel, because I
think your work really has
encompasses so
many of the themes
that we've been seeing
here, and has been I
think inspirational to a lot
of people, including myself.
And I think what
this panel embodies
in microcosm is certainly
the type of analysis
which I think on the
computational side
that I think people
have been increasingly
aspiring to, to actually bring
the mathematical formalism
in the models, into a
closer conversation,
both with the arts and
the social sciences.
And to understand how it
can inform that discussion
without as Ruha said overly
dominating that discussion.
Thanks so much.
It's been a cultural humility.
You made me feel very
humble in your remarks.
To you as well as
appreciating your insights.
So Behnaz?
Can you also share
a final remark?
Of course.
And I just want to very
briefly echo Jon's comments.
And I want to say
that also thank you,
Fox, for organizing this panel.
I've learned from all
the speakers here.
I think the opportunities
for artists, and designers,
and to learn from
other disciplines.
But also have the sort of
transdisciplinary approach
that can learn and borrow
from each discipline's, it's
incredible in this
period of time.
So I'm extremely excited
about the possibility
of learning from
other disciplines,
and bringing those ideas
into my own discipline in art
and design.
So thank you so much for
creating and fostering
this platform.
Well thank you so much.
And I want to finally
just extend a heartfelt
thanks to Ruha, Jon
and Behnaz for agreeing
to join this panel.
I've learned so much and been
so inspired by all of the things
that you have said.
And also thanking the
co-conveners of the symposium.
And those who came up with the
idea of Unfolding Intelligence
as convening maybe a year or
more ago, and to see it finally
come to fruition in this
time of great reckoning we
find ourselves in right now.
So it's just an astounding, and
impressive, and valuable feat
to bring us all together here.
So thank you very much.
Thanks to our audience.
Thank you.
Thank you to our
audience as well.
And have a great rest
of the symposium.